okay well do one more we're almost out
of time so I'll do this company I don't
know how you say it ty Eve its ta ivy ty
a weird name don't know why they chose
that name but whatever so what these
guys are doing is they you know how
every bar or restaurant has TVs and
they're playing sports usually or
whatever it is so what they're saying is
hey the commercial break that's a lost
opportunity right so what they do is
they hijack the commercial break on that
TV and they just upsell stuff from your
menu so you know you're watching the
game when the commercial happens it'll
show the wings that they have on the
menu it'll be like nine dollars for
these wings right now you want it it's a
commercial just locally for your bar or
restaurant I love this idea because I
think there's a lot of restaurants out
there who who are in this scenario they
have you know Blatz of bars lots of rest
just ahead TV so I think there's a
decent market for it I like the idea of
helping them make money it's a very
simple solution but the thing is most
these restaurants and bars haven't done
anything yet so like this is a there's a
lot of low-hanging fruits still
available this is one that I like it's
like sort of an ad block for those TVs
what I think might be challenging for
them is selling into bars and
restaurants I think that's gonna be a
slow and painful process for them
alright I have a little background info
information on the CEO tribe TV know
what's that okay so you know the Chive
calm yeah okay the Chive calm the
founders leo
it's and I know Leo and John Leo is one
of my investors and someone I look up to
he started the Chive and he now they
have chive TV and weight started was
they would get like a lot of funny
videos like America's funny some videos
looks like dad's getting hit in the nuts
by their kids swinging a pinata baseball
bat like just silly stuff and in all of
Texas what they did was they would give
these bar owners these little dongles
like these like fire sticks like an
Amazon fire stick and they uploaded all
this programming and they
just like constantly filling the pipes
and so if you go to the bar you see just
like America's Funniest Home Videos in
the background and chive would put their
ads in the in the mix and they made
millions of dollars doing it and so much
so that they eventually spun it off into
a different company and they call it
atmosphere TV and they've just raised
ten million dollars to launch it and Leo
was like this is gonna be a
multi-billion dollar business and
interesting so I have now the verdicts
still out if that's gonna happen but
chive TV was huge for the Chive
atmosphere he says it's gonna be the
greatest thing ever and he said that
what they need to do is just go out and
hire the same thing that I described
earlier hire those people how you go
yeah we're just gonna hire a ton of
salespeople and we're gonna do this and
then another bit of background is you
and I talked to the folks at Firefly
yeah I won't put words in your mouth but
I have no problem in saying I thought
that was a horribly dumb to do good idea
and this idea is a little bit similar
but I think way better right yeah more
defensible for sure fireflies the
company that puts a little add a little
billboard thing on top of it uber uber
driver can make a little more money
that's cool but this is this is a little
bit different this is more what I'll
call it's not dependent on the ad market
which I like your internally advertising
stuff in the restaurant or the bar to
get people to have a little higher check
size yeah but that's not what they're
saying that in their deck they say at
first they're doing what you're
describing right and they go they said
all of our one-year contracts are
insanely profitable but our next phase
is to sell ad time at $25 per CPM
interesting okay all right so maybe
maybe the in restaurant upsell is not as
good as I thought and that's why they're
like already planning to go out of that
and I think that's a good market but
will in their numbers what they're
assuming they're saying they're gonna
have a $25 CPM that's gonna make us way
more money and create this new 32
billion dollar market and begin the math
is that we have X amount of impressions
and we're gonna put $25 CPM ads on there
now here's the problem which is their
fill rate is not going to be a hundred
right
and it's not I'm gonna be close to 100%
yeah so that's a little ridiculous
here's the other thing I don't like so
they charge forty two hundred dollars
per location per year that's really
expensive for a restaurant or bar they
also charge a one-time $1500 hardware
installation and so I just think that
they've added a lot of friction to the
adoption of this I think already it was
gonna be hard to get people to adopt
that's a high price point and a high
one-time installation fee that they're
asking people to do so I think that's
that seems tough for me that said I
think that this this could be a business
that makes 10 20 30 40 50 million
dollars a year in sales this is a great
company to own not a great company to
invest not a great company if they raise
all this money that's my opinion
yeah that make sense oh I like this they
just had someone smart once told me he's
the only thing that you can't screw up
in business is your cap table and so
when I look at when I look at a lot of
these companies I think that could be
good so salt so long as they don't screw
up their cap table right yeah that is
one way to die for the wrong reasons
that's a great way to put it
[Music]